I remember talking to my dad and telling
my dad as a little girl when I grow up
I'm gonna be an actress I'm gonna be
writing and every report card came with
she talks too much if you don't know
what I'm saying let me explain this to
you I am Nigerian and in Nigeria back in
the day you had to be a doctor a lawyer
or a nobody that was what rained so I
went to med school because that was the
easiest way for me in my heart I always
wanted to speak my whole life I have
done things for other people but this
time I want to do for me who I truly am
because here's what I know if I don't do
me the world is going to miss out and
you as well can you imagine a world
without Einstein or can you imagine a
world without Steve Jobs oh you have the
safe jobs of your life there's something
you have to contribute that you're not
contributing just like me yes I'm a
physician I do a good job but can you
imagine what our lives would be in one
year if only we step out and be
ourselves
so we're here Dr o which is part of the
Mastermind and doing our one-on-one
together so what do you got doctor how
can I help oh
so when I first met you I think it was
2019 or 2020. I think it was 2019 first
before I went to Puerto Rico with
Brandon
um
I have a YouTube channel because I like
to talk it's a good start yeah
I like to talk as a little girl
um
on my report card the the constant of my
report card was talks too much
and um but it kept coming out and so
when I mentioned I was like hey this is
the guy that does the YouTube channel
deal and I really want to have a YouTube
channel
um because I I really know that people
listen
when what you say affects their lives
and when they see that they can make
results and if it's simple
um but I couldn't figure out how to
communicate
what I really wanted to do because I had
so many things written in my head
um
I'm a physician
because my dad was I'm a people person
so in that world it's a little different
than the world that I want to build I
want to build a world where
people do what they love so that they
are not doing any work because I notice
in healthcare a lot of people are good
tasks
but they have no people skills at all
and people are people if you don't treat
them right they can't get well if you
treat them right with little medicine
they get well just like the nuns did and
that's what I want to do in healthcare
because that was that's my Niche at
first I didn't want to do the niche
thing
you know I think I have this Rebel
streak in me you know it's right there I
think I do I have this Rebel streak in
me if you tell me to do something it's
like
can I find a way to kind of get to the
edge yeah so
I think I can blame my parents for that
the the
um my parents were outliers my mom went
to school first time when she was 12.
um she did things a little different and
I think they gave me the freedom to be
me in healthcare there's no freedom to
be you you have to cookie cutter and it
doesn't work people do not come
uh like a machine
people are unique even though we're
Universal
and my messaging is this
look
everybody wants to be heard
and everybody wants to know that they
matter
no matter where they're from no matter
whether they're sick or not and in
healthcare we don't have that messaging
it's a little different and I want to
change that
especially for the healthcare providers
because I believe you can't give what
you don't have
I mean that that's my main theme
um and a lot of us have burnt out even
before covid
but kovit has taken a toll on us
that's my messaging but before I was
running from medicine because
I just couldn't figure out what I wanted
to do but now I'm real clear
um especially women Physicians that's
who I really want to address
because we have the load of both
medicine and life being women and that's
still a woman that's all I know
um and I think I need to start from what
I know first so
I think you've got
a really powerful message
and a really powerful voice
and even though you you know haven't
been consistent on making content to
being a speaker it's you've been
speaking your whole life
and now it's turning that into something
that actually has a much bigger impact
than than I'm sure when you speak with
people one-on-one you change their life
it's now how do we take that message and
bring it to millions of people
but how happy are you being a physician
like could you do it for five more years
no okay I can't I'm being a physician
now out of habit and and I have to be
honest I'm actually way better than I've
ever been as a physician because
um
I'm actually scripting
what I want Physicians to be like in my
own life
so I it's like when I go to work now
it's like
I've seen myself looking down at myself
acting who I want a physician to be I do
so I mean like I'm actually scripting
and acting like I want a physician to be
like
but it's telling me to be I'm exhausted
you know like I can do it because I've
done it
but I'm I'm just a robot and and I think
that's a disservice to me and my
patients because is it your own practice
or you you work at a hospital or I'm an
Emergency Physician and
the the medicine in in the United States
where I was very toxic yeah
um toxic among physician to physician
Physicians to other parts of the team
when I go to work
and make a difference
but I think I'll make it in a much
greater difference if I can teach
Physicians and what I know see what I
mean like almost like if I duplicate
myself as opposed to me being in the
practice
but I can't figure that out
oh I tell myself I can't figure it out
because I tell stories all the time so
I'm not sure which one it is
if you started consistently making
content
you have a chance to to be a really
powerful voice
for your industry and I think Beyond
you have to get consistent
doctor oh you know like everything else
you gotta stay consistent but but it's
also
it takes time like even if you're really
good it takes time not just getting
comfortable with the camera but honing
the message
being concise clear and building the
brand all that takes time and we can
help do that the question becomes in the
time that it takes to build that brain
and turn it into something what do we do
to make money
and so
if you don't want to be a physician in
the next five years
we need to figure out a different way to
monetize your expertise
is there another physician rule that's
not ER that is at a better company that
respects what you do that pays you
better that you're not working as many
crazy hours it's not as toxic
um I used to be a family physician and
um the reason I did ER was
with the ER I have more
control over my time like it's shift
work so I can decide I don't want to
work like if I was a family physician I
could be in Toronto because
probably my boss would be like ah we
don't have anybody to cover you your
shift yeah you know because I'm you know
I'm a family physician but because I'm
an ER physician I blocked the time and
said I'm not available so it's a little
different the only thing I know that is
direct physician
is to be a physician leader which means
I'm going to be corporate and I hate
corporate I I I'm not caught up for
admin at all because they're so far
removed from reality in my opinion you
know
um I believe that the one thing that I
should do which I'm shied away from is
coach Physicians
um and honestly I'm used to sending my
resume and getting a job even though I'm
an independent contractor
and I just have I'm talking to myself as
I'm talking now to say you gotta ask for
the money my problem is I don't ask for
the money do I coach 50 yes I do but I
don't get paid because I never ask for
the money you certainly like so it's not
as of today it's not a viable source for
me because I never asked for the money I
don't have an offer to ask for the money
yeah yeah and we could work on that yeah
or like those are your two paths you
become an entrepreneur while you're
building your brand you're becoming an
entrepreneur and
learning the skills of creating the
coaching program and asking for the
money and sales and all that stuff
or it's get a better job
to support what you're doing in a less
toxic environment that's more fun while
with both while still making your
content
because ultimately with your message and
your voice you
it's hard to know where you're gonna end
up like magical things will happen
whether you're speaking on stage writing
books being on TV having your own show
creating your own products being on
Boards of Directors for companies that
have
are in the healthcare space like there's
if you become the voice for an industry
so many things open up that you you
can't even you know imagine like it's
being open to the magical world of what
could be but none of it happens if
you're not making content and getting
the message out right I mean it's it's
inside you but now we have to show the
world that you can create this so so
that has to happen you know for you
right like you're a speaker let's see
you speaking but in the process of that
taking three years to build up what are
we doing
to make money
and it's either be an entrepreneur and
learn how to sell which is which may not
be comfortable it's definitely
uncomfortable but maybe what you want to
do maybe you want to have coaching
clients maybe that's a path you want to
take or get a better job
which do you want to do for the next
three years I think I'm 62 years old and
yesterday I was 69 one month so for me
I'm like
all right girlfriend
I like you call yourself girlfriend
that's great I mean I thought to myself
girlfriend that's great I'm a God real
thing I don't call myself boyfriend no
that's good I don't have a girlfriend
you're playing
that's great I learned I said to myself
I was like how do you show your children
that there's another way other than
going to college and waiting for a gold
watch
because right now what I'm doing is I'm
telling my kids you go to college
whenever you went to college so that's
what you do the rest of your life so for
me it I have put a spin on it that I've
that has helped me and I said the only
way I can show my children
is for me to be my voice and for me to
be my voices I need to put content
On video okay so that's going to happen
regardless like that's why you're here
we're going to hold your cannibal we're
going to get you more videos and I said
but for me to do that I need to look at
my life like this is September right
I've already worked in the ER 192 hours
this half a month
because that's what I do I work so ask
myself if you continue to work in
medicine we will happy you get better
but is that what you want to do so I
have decided to sit with my hours and
put hours into this
content
and making offers just as I went to
Mexico I didn't know what I was doing
first time I got my degree
I saw my name I was like ah how fast
and then I remember
I went to the ER
which I didn't want to be in Pediatric
ER in Nigeria Lagos and my very first
patient in my life was dead
and I choked and I went to my city and I
said what am I supposed to do and she's
like you're the doctor like I am
my name was on the board I was a doctor
so I asked myself I'm like you gotta go
back to that same place
you learned to be a doctor you never had
practice
but you went to work and you're done so
I told myself you're in Toronto
you got a qualifications as a coach
you need to coach
you need to you need to be scared as you
were that time 30 something years ago
because if you're not then you're just
trifling that's what I told my
girlfriend which is me
so
um like I'm making a video tonight you
know because tonight I'm making that
video and say hey
and I have people in my real estate I'm
going to call send the video saying I
said I'm starting this question do you
want to say it or not
and the reason is because I know I know
a lot of people my age who they're there
because of practice not because they
want to be there so you're going to make
a video that's going to say what let's
go see
look at us
we started as kids
we perfected the art of medicine but at
this stage of Our Lives
that's not what we really want to do
what is that one thing you wish you did
just before you go to the other side are
you doing it now I coach people to do
the same because I'm doing the same in
my life you want to come on the journey
with me or not
and the reason why is because for me
um
it hit me hard
this past uh
month actually week
I was at work and I sent a text to a
friend of mine
saying that I was thinking of hand
praying for her
and by the time I send the text
I did not know her husband had passed
and he was a doctor like us but he
decided to be a minister and ended up
being one of the um
one of the first black bishops in 20
years
in the UK and I asked myself the
question I was like damn girl what are
you still doing playing playing you know
and for me it was really emotional
because I was at work it was a full
distant and I kept asking myself
and this past week everybody's been
calling me to work and I'm just ignoring
them because I'm like I need to do me
and for this stage of my life
I need to coach and I need to speak the
things in my heart okay so here's what
we're gonna do instead of you you're
gonna we're gonna you're gonna record
this tonight what at your at your home
yes okay at my Airbnb I got my phone I
got myself yeah
so instead of you doing that yes you're
gonna look into that camera okay this
one that's your camera all right you're
gonna record it with the nice setup
okay and then we're gonna cut it for you
and we're gonna send it you're gonna be
able to use this for your coaching
practice okay okay so when you're ready
you look in there Arthur all good
my name is falakia Lucan um
you might know me or you might not
I just want to share a story with you my
dad was a doctor
and as a little girl I remember going
with my dad to work and reading the less
digest my mom was a nurse my mom worked
in the ER
I never knew the impact both of my
parents would have on my life
I ended up being a doctor and guess what
ended up being the ER just like my mom
in 2015
I found out my personality type
on paper I'm not cut out to be a doctor
if you're familiar with disk
I am an idsc which means the C part is
what most doctors are
it's the bottom of for me
but I learned to be a physician I
learned the way I learned the practice
and I practiced what I learned
I am an awesome physician
but let me tell you what I why I'm
making this video today
in my heart I remember talking to my dad
and telling my dad
as a little girl when I grow up I'm
going to be an actress I'm going to be
writing
and every report card came with she
talks too much
if you don't know what I'm saying let me
explain this to you I am Nigerian and in
Nigeria back in the day
you had to be a doctor
a lawyer an architect an engineer or a
nobody
that was what reigned so I went to med
school because that was the easiest way
for me
but in my heart I always wanted to speak
here I am 62 years old
wanting to speak but in practice I have
been a physician for over 30 years and
that's all I know
I'm terrified
but I'm not
I'm telling myself a story because I
talk
how about you
you might be in your 40s you might be in
your 30s
you might be in your 60s
can I challenge you
are you really really living your life
or the life that you think you should
live for your parents
I'm glad for my parents because I know
for a fact
if they were not my parents I probably
some Dropout or some drug addict because
I just like to play and party
but I stayed in school because of my
parents I was more scared of my friends
than anything else
at this stage of my life
I want to invite you to join me in
exploring who you truly are on the
inside that you've never explored
I want to give a shout out to my
daughter
she's a chef in Los Angeles
she never went to culinary school matter
of fact she went to college and got a
health administration degree and a
master's because of me because I'm a
forceful Nigerian mother
but she found at 25 that she didn't want
to work in corporate
and she crafted her own niche
as a chef
my whole life I have done things for
other people
but this time I want to do for me who I
truly am
because here's what I know
if I don't do me the world is going to
miss out
and you as well
can you imagine a world without Einstein
or can you imagine a world without Steve
Jobs oh you have the safe jobs of your
life
there's something you have to contribute
that you're not contributing just like
me
yes I'm a physician I did a good job
but can you imagine what our lives would
be in one year if only we step out and
be ourselves
as I'm challenging you I'm challenging
myself am I terrified yeah but guess
what it's like when I go to Six Flags
and I get on a roller coaster I have the
same emotional feeling and that's what
I'm saying right now
I don't even know what I said but here's
one thing I know
this is a time for you and I to go on a
coaching experience what does that mean
a coach is
a vehicle that takes you from where you
are to where you want to go
and a coaching practices where I as the
tour guide I'm going to be with you on
that coach taking us from where we are
now from where we're supposed to be
imagine for a moment
you wanting to be
in a place
and dreaming of that place
and you open your eyes and you're there
last year
I found myself in Sydney
Sydney Opera House
I saw Sydney Opera House when I was an
11 year old kid in Nigeria
I saw it in a Reader's Digest and I said
one day I'll be there
and at 61 I found myself there
it's never too late to be yourself
join me my name for Lucky Luke
thank you
there it is
Dr o
[Laughter]
oh
to watch me coach another Mastermind
member one-on-one check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there